who doesn't love a wedding
[Applause]
[Music]
Doctor Who series 11 continues on and we
have the demons of Punjab and this one I
really I ought to say I'd no idea what
to expect from this one and as it got
started I was very nervous because
immediately we're doing a go back in
time to meet a relative that you didn't
know because they died before you were
born
and I immediately got you know big
clanging alarm bells of Father's Day be
kid which I mean I'm on record is not
liking but then again the reason the
main reason I don't like Father's Day
are the Reapers I really hate those
things
so like there is stuff to be done with
it but at the same time I thought even
if this does it well it's gonna be
repeating something that I've already
seen Doctor Who do you know do I really
want to watch this but as it went along
it was it was doing something different
because whereas Father's Day was about
sort of getting a little bit demystified
and having a sense of somebody who
you've heard stories of but it never met
in the case of the demons the punjab
it's about understanding how much more
there is to the life story of someone
who you do know but like I said a lot
more going on there and so we've got
dadoes are set up there are of course
aliens that get involved and it's a
little bit of an interesting sort of
angle that that comes at it from and
overall I liked it and I don't I don't
know what the general reaction is like
like I said I usually tend to avoid it
but it I get I feel like they whatever
negative vibe there is among the fandom
or at least some stripes of the fandom
has been building across the series so I
think potentially there's there's
probably been a not great reaction to
this I like it
quite a bit there's a number of things I
like about it but ultimately the main
thing that I like about it
has to do with the emotional connections
and the journey that yaz goes through in
relation to her grandmother and I will
be flat-out honest I'm not saying this
is a flawless story but I will
acknowledge and I often do that if you
can connect something with something at
the correct emotional level it papers
over a lot of faults and I think that is
frequently what can be the case with
something like Father's Day which I know
connected with a lot of people much more
strongly than it did me on an emotional
level so for me you know I in his in
something like Father's Day I was left
in a situation where I understood what
the emotional hook was and I'm not gonna
say it didn't work but it didn't work on
me and so that meant that I was left
with a story that I just saw a lot of
faults in whereas this I did connect the
emotional bit of it did and so while
there are issues I don't feel them as
much because it made the emotional
connection and then that that can make
all the difference now I suspect if for
whatever reason it didn't connect
emotionally with people that they
probably won't take as much of a liking
to it because whether or not - the
emotional stakes it's still a good story
or not I think it's still a pretty
decent story all things told it is at
its heart and emotional story that is
the main angle that's going for so if
that's as a connect it's still gonna
leave you with what is gonna feel like a
bit of a half experience because the
main push of it was something that
didn't work for you but again it did for
me and sort of the big thing for me was
like I I could connect and relate with
yazz and and you know coming to a better
understanding of her grandmother's life
you know remind me more than a little
bit of my own mother because my while my
mother had never been one to you know
omit details or or sugarcoat her life
you know it a life a lifetime to tell
somebody accurately what your life was
like would take a lifetime so whenever
you relay your story to somebody you
whether it is you know stuff that you
didn't think matter there's stuff that
you have a one reason or another to not
wish to share it either with that
specific person or at all and you know
as I've gotten older and I've you know
had you know some more in-depth than
longer conversations with my mother
about things she's been through and I've
gotten a clearer picture of of what
she's gone through in her life and what
she's endured it's you know it didn't
necessarily like kind of shake me the
serve no no like that yes goes through
but like that's sort of having to
reformulate and re in and understand the
person and the life behind the stories
and the image you have of someone even
someone in your life in your family who
you connect strongly with that can cause
a disconnect and that can take some
getting over and she does and I quite
like that and so as a result that worked
really well for me I found the setting
interesting i outweigh it might make me
appreciate rose a little bit more it
doesn't erase the issues that I have
with that story I might revisit some of
that when I do it end of series wrap up
sort of thing but I'll tell you that as
someone who doesn't know a ton about
India's history this was a chunk of it
that I mean I got I got what was going
on they it I think they did it really
well because again speaking as an
American this was a piece of history and
a piece the world that I didn't really
know much about really at all so they
addressed just enough about what was
going on to make it clear why this was
going to cause problems and presented me
with something where on my oh dang
yeah that would make for a really ugly
situation in that part of the world holy
cow
I really didn't fully understand that
that's kind of how we got in some ways
to where we are now
you know with with certain parts of the
world on the way certain things are and
I think it was it was decently handled
again I I have to assume a decent level
of accuracy on it because again I don't
know so that I have to kind of make a
leap of faith on my part there so the
the but the the thing is is that because
it
unlike Rosa which is dealing with a
known historical figure this is dealing
with a known historical situation and
with invented people I think that gives
you a little bit of leeway but you know
seeing the the breaking of families and
the split between neighbors and people
who care about each other but the the
divisions just get stoked
whether purposefully or not but by the
by the situations and by the
circumstances and there are people who
take advantage of that and there are
people who lean into their own worst
feelings about what's going on too hard
and again that rang pretty true for me
and I thought that worked well the alien
element I it was interesting it wasn't
bad I'm not sure how much it actually
adds though at the end of the day it's
kind of a neat idea yet it's also more
than a little bit reminiscent of what
was going on and twice upon a time with
the sort of glass beings who were
retaining the memories of people from
their moment of death this whole notion
of a race sort of honoring the the not
the food not the Forgotten dead
necessarily but the the people who died
alone and you know witnessing them so
that you know someone's there it's kind
of an interesting idea but it did remind
me more than a little of that I think
that bothers me a little bit more than
the general set up feeling like Father's
Day because it's for God's sakes it's
been what 13 years since Father's Day I
figure that's fair game to revisit that
general premise again twice upon a time
was less than a year ago so that that
one feel that element feels a little bit
more
live in terms of stuff that's gone on
recently with the show but again in a
myself it worked it was kind it was kind
of decent if I had a complaint it's one
that I might not have about the episode
in isolation but it's a vibe I'm getting
in general about the show and this kind
of feeds into it which is that I feel
like Whitaker's doctor is passives the
wrong word but she feels much more
separate and apart from events then I'm
used to the doctor being I don't know if
that's an upshot of how much sort of Wow
how much this only the second one but I
mean you know dealing with the real
world history can get dicey that's part
of it but even like beyond that you know
I even even the other episodes that that
I've enjoyed or even some of the ones I
haven't she she feels very much either
more of an observer or just kind of
along for the ride I don't get the sense
of her taking control of the situation
and I mean that's not to say that I like
need her to demand that everyone listen
to her it's I don't know it's it just
seems a little less oh let's get stuck
in
then I'm used to I need to think on that
a little bit more because I mean she's
getting into the situation's but again
there's there's just a passive it is too
strong a word but I can't think I can't
think of a gentler one that is in the
same vein and that's throwing me off a
little again if I restrict it to any
specific episode it's not it's like fine
but it's the pattern of it that I feel
like I'm seeing that's throwing me off a
little bit and and there's the scene
that yes has with Graham which is a
great scene with Graham kind of opening
a rise up about you know what I've kind
of talked about like you know this woman
you're meeting now she's not your nan
yet she's not that pert she'll become
that person but she isn't
now and she wasn't gonna tell you
absolutely everything that ever happened
to her you know you need to remember
that she was a person a different person
from long before you were even born
much less got to know her and it was a
good scene but I felt like the doctor
should really be having this
conversation because in in more than a
few ways it reminded me of the second
doctor talking with Victoria in tombs of
the Cybermen which is one of my favorite
second doctor scenes ever one of my
favorite Doctor Who seems to be
completely blunt about it and that scene
in this episode between Graham and yes
it was good it was still good and I
liked it and I'm liking Graham a lot but
I'm just left thinking I wish that was
the doctor talking to her in this scene
and I think that maybe that's part of
the passivity since like I feel like
she's not making the connections with
the companions as much and part of that
might be because of how many of them
there are like I get that she wants a
strong can I should live them but I
don't feel like it's being built I feel
like I'm watching the connections
between the companions get stronger but
I'm not seeing the bond between the
doctor and the Companions get stronger
and again that's more of a ramble of
like where the series is as a whole I
don't really want to level that against
this episode specifically because again
in isolation I actually quite like this
episode and I I was I was surprised like
I was really skeptical going into this
once I just once I latched on to the
premise and I got what was going on I
was prepared to just groan my way
through this but I it it connected and
it worked for me and I was I was
surprised how well but I am noticing
things in it that are things that I'm
noticing in other episodes that are
creating sort of larger scale hmmm
things so I guess I guess I'll wrap it
up there I liked the episode I liked it
a lot I but I'm I'm starting to get a
firmer grip on some of the large
scale things going on in the series
overall that aren't quite working for me
those those ideas are solidifying in my
head at the same time that is that I'm
seeing an episode that I actually rather
enjoy so there you go there's that bit
of weirdness for you so deem is a Punjab
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts were dropped something
down in the comments let's talk about it
please be respectful I am actually
getting a little bit irritated at how
many people that I am having to block
and ban off the channel out of the
comment sections for personal attacks
just remember if you do a personal
attack against another commenter against
me against the people involved in the
show I'm gonna remove it and there's a
decent chance I'm just gonna block you
and also let's be clear I don't have the
time of patients to sort through the
ones being done for real and the ones
being done as a joke anymore and if I
delete your comment but you meant it as
a joke tough like just don't be a joke
okay so assuming you gonna buy buy that
sorry that got a little bit more then I
meant to to but assuming that you can
and again you can be as critical as you
want just don't be mean to people and
don't be rude so keep your thoughts
polite and drop them down in the
comments let's talk about it there's a
whole bunch of stuff you can do there as
well because there's buttons and there's
links including links to my patreon if
you feel like supporting the show that
way even if you don't there's other
links for you to check out and besides
that you know what end of the day you
don't even have to worry about it
because you're the council and I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]